In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for July 3 on which we commemorate the Holy Martyrs
Mark and Mokios.
Some in to sacrifice to idols by the prefect Maximus, these glorious martyrs resisted, confessing
the name of Christ, and were immediately condemned to death by beheading.
When Saint Mokios was taken to the scaffold, his wife and children followed him, weeping,
but confirmed in the love of Christ who has taught us to renounce everything, even
Kinsfolk, wife, and children to follow him.
The saint exhorted them to keep quiet and dry their tears.
When Mark's turn came, his wife was also present.
Having overcome the fleshly bonds, she joyfully took her spouse's head in her hands and bore
it away as a precious treasure, thus having her share in the glory of the Holy Martyrs.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on
us and save us.